البرلمان اللبناني يفشلوا للمره العاشره
في انتخاب رئيس للبلاد اول تعليق النادي
وليد الرجراجي بعد مباراه المغرب وفرنسا
كريستيانو رونالدو يعود الى معقل تدريبات
ريال مدريد
تقريبا
بعد المباراه المثيره امام فرنسا والتي
انتهت بخساره المغرب بهدفين دون رد عبر
مدرب المنتخب المغربي وليد الرجراجي عن
شعوره بالفخر بلاعبيه الذين بدلوا كل ما
في وسعهم رغم الاصابات وفي مؤتمر الصحفي
اعترف الرجراجيبي ارتكاب اخطاء فنيه قائلا
ان لاعبي خلقوا للفرنسيين المتاعب في
الشوط الاول وفي الثاني كانوا الافضل حيث
لم يخسر الكره كثيرا وصنعه كثيرا من
الفراس لكنهم لم يكونوا حاسمينا في
الامتار ال 30 الاخيره واضاف حاولنا الضغط
حتى النهايه لتسجيل هدف ينعش املانا
ولكننا لم نتمكن فيما سيخوض المنتخب
المغربي مباراه تحديدا المركزينا الثالث
والرابع في مواجهته كرواتيا يوم السبت
المقبل
بعدها فوزي منتخب الديوك على اسود الاطلس
القى الشرطه الفرنسيه القبض على مجموعه من
الاشخاص ينتمون لليمين المتطرف كانوا
وينمون مهاجمه المشجعين المغاربه نافقه
باسم شرطه الفرنسيه
ان 200 هو
66 شخصا اعتقلوا بعد اعمال عنف وشغب في
انحاء البلاد عقب نهايه المباراه من بينهم
1067 فردا في العاصمه باريس فيما كشف ممثل
الادعاء ان 40 شخصا من اليمين المتضرر
والقى القبض عليهم بعضهم يحمل اسلحه بيضاء
[موسيقى]
في خبر اللاق انتشارا واسعا على السوشيال
ميديا عاده كريستيانو رونالدو مره اخرى
الى نادي ريال مدريد الاسباني وذلك لخوض
التدريبات في منشات المدينه الرياضيه
للنادي الملكي موقع ريليفيو الاسباني افاد
بان نجم البرتغالي عاد لمركز تدريبات ريال
مدريد بعد رحيله بشكل رسمي عن مانشستر
يونايتد من اجل التدرب على ملعب المنفصل
للحفاظ على لياقته البدنيه بعيدا عن اعين
المتطفلين مشيرا الى ان عودته جاءت بعد
موافقه اداره النادي على طلبه اذن لحوض
التدريبات في منشات المدينه الرياضيه
ما في خبرنا الاخير قال الملياردير
الامريكي لهم ماسك انه يتخذ اجراءات
قانونيه ضد صاحب حساب في تويتر لتتبع
طائرته الخاصه بحجه انه عرض ابنه للخطر
موقع تويتر علق قبل ساعات حساب ايلنجات
الذي يتابعه اكثر من نصف مليون شخص حيث
كان يستخدم معلومات تتبع الرحلات المتاحه
للجمهور للتغريد في كل مره تقلع فيها
طائره مصر
في تغريده ان السياره التي كانت تحمل ابنه
في لوس انجلوس تبعها مطارد مجنون ومنعاها
لاحقا من التحرك وتسلق مقدماتها ملتحمه
صاحب حساب بالوقوفي